úrsula von der leyen y sal michelle han
acompañado a pedro sánchez para la
visita del centro europeo logístico que
podrá acoger hasta 800 afganos después
serán redistribuidos por los diferentes
países de la unión europea durante este
evento la unión ha aclarado su posición
y su estrategia frente a la crisis
actualmente está dialogando con los
talibanes pero solo porque es un
contacto necesario en el medio de la
crisis no se les considera como actores
como interlocutores políticos la unión
europea también dice que quiere ser
unida y solidaria con los afganos dice
que quiere luchar contra la trata de
seres humanos pero al mismo tiempo
también quiere controlar los flujos
migratorios según sánchez von der leyen
y michel la prioridad ahora es dialogar
con la otan la onu y los eeuu para
salvar a los afganos colaboradores de la
unión europea que están bloqueados en el
aeropuerto de kabul